- This meal of eating all
together is called a Botram
and it helps to kind of
lean over so you can get
a lot of food into your mouth.
(speaking foreign language)
The flavors are just insane.
(island music)
Good morning everyone its Mark
Wiens with migrationology.com
in Jakarta, Indonesia.
Today Ken and Gratia
have invited Ying and I
to go on a family trip with
them to a place called Punchak.
(inspirational music)
We are driving towards Bogor,
which is about 30 minutes to
an hour depending on traffic
but this morning, traffic
looks pretty light,
so we should be there pretty soon.
(inspirational music)
Made it to Bogor and we kind
of drove through the city
to the other side and
we're still in the city
but it feels like countryside here
and our first stop we are at a place
that serves Laksa Bogor.
Oh not noodle okay.
- Rice noodle.
- [Mark] Rice noodle okay.
- [Man] And it's been fermented.
- So she puts rice, cakes
in the bottom of the bowl
and then a bunch of bean
sprouts and then rice noodles
and then after that.
Also that's the Laksa curry sauce.
It looks very thick.
That looks awesome.
Oh I think I can smell some ginger
and maybe tumeric in there.
That steam smells amazing.
(engines whirring)
I got my bowl of Laksa Bogor
and there are actually
rice cakes on the bottom
plus the noodles and
then she added in a bunch
of bean sprouts and some vegetables
and then she topped it
with some other seasonings
and then added in the curry sauce and then
on the top is some shredded
coconut, which has been,
it's been cooked, stir-fried?
Oh deep fried okay.
Oh that is wonderful.
It has a really fragrant
ginger, maybe ginger,
and lemongrass kind of flavor to it
and then also that coconut.
The coconut really comes in nicely.
Oh that's nice.
It's kind of a, kind of
like a sweet herbal flavor.
Okay they also have some
Sambal, which you can add.
I'm gonna try some of this Sambal.
And I think that is
rice cake on this bite.
Mmmm, yeah that is a
spicy Sambal actually.
Oh yeah.
It is spicy and a little bit sour
and it's very popular to eat
the Krupuk, which are crackers
with the curry and so I have
reached the bottom of the bowl
and you can dip it into
all that rich coconut milk
curry sauce.
Oh that is good.
The cracker is really crispy
but then it just kind of soaks
up all of that curry sauce.
That was really good and a
much different type of Laksa,
a much different mixture of ingredients
than any other type of Laksa
I've ever had in Malaysia
or Singapore.
Hello.
We just drove down the
street just a couple minutes
and we are at our next
food stop, which serves,
it's called Toge Goreng,
which is fried bean sprouts
but it is some kind of interesting
dish that is very famous
from right here.
They are cooking over a wood fire
and then there is a big
bowl full of bean sprouts.
Okay so he first grabs
some, oh some rice cake
and then he's gonna go in for some,
he chooses some of the bean sprouts
from the boiling water
there so he puts them
onto the rice cakes.
Oh and then he's just
grabbing a handful of noodles,
just quickly blanching them
and then into the bowl.
And then he dumps out all of the water.
And then on, I think that's some tofu
and then he goes on with some,
I think it's soybean sauce.
Oh and something in a Heineken bottle.
These guys are so good at what they do
that I bet they could
make this entire dish
with their eyes closed.
They do it so rhythmically
and so expertly.
I just got my bowl of the dish
and although the name
is fried bean sprouts,
it's actually not fried at all,
it's boiled bean sprouts or
just blanched bean sprouts
with a bunch of different ingredients.
And then they also served
some Sambal in the spoon
so I will just sort of mix it around.
I guess I gotta, I gotta try
some of those bean sprouts
and some of the rice cake.
Mmmmmm, oh yeah.
That has a very unique flavor.
I think from that fermented bean sauce.
Yeah it has a little bit of
a fermented flavor to it,
definitely, kind of, not quite cheese
but starting to get to the cheese flavor
and then it's kind of sweet
and salty at the same time
as well.
And then those bean
sprouts are really crisp
but then you've got
pieces of soft rice cake
and silky soft tofu as well.
That's a very interesting
mix and a lot of textures
going on.
Definitely the key to that dish
is the fermented soybean sauce.
That's where most of the
flavor was coming from
and they said that they grill the soybeans
right here in this area.
That's where all the flavor was
and then the beansprouts
and the other tofu
and the rice cakes just
kind of give it some body
and some texture.
(inspirational music)
Hello.
We have just arrived to the
country home in the rice fields
and this is where we're gonna
spend I think most of the day
just relaxing here and
enjoying the countryside.
It's really beautiful.
We are in the rice paddy fields.
Oh I didn't even know.
This is a Durian tree.
I'm standing right
underneath a Durian Tree.
I was just walking around.
I didn't even realize I
was standing underneath
a Durian tree.
(clucking and chattering)
- [Man] The round one is Misro.
- [Mark] Misro.
- [Man] The long one is Combro.
- Combro.
And it's deep fried some
kind of cassava fritter.
Mmmmm.
That is really crispy and then
kind of gooey in the inside
and then in the middle is
I think it's soybean right?
It looks like minced meat
but it's actually soybean.
Oh that's delicious.
This one is supposed to be
the sweet one called Misro.
It tastes kind of like
honey but it's palm sugar.
And now having some coconut
water and coconut meat
straight from the coconuts.
These are young coconuts,
so the meat is very soft.
And I think these came from a tree right
around here somewhere.
Coconut is one of the
greatest things in the world.
Oh that's just pure buttery
coconut and it's not too sweet,
but so creamy buttery.
Oh man it's good.
And that coconut meat is so
young that it just dissolves
as you eat it.
I am loving this place.
It is a fruit paradise.
There are rice fields but then
surrounding the rice fields,
there are Durian trees,
there are guava trees,
banana trees, there are
I think a Rambutan tree.
What else did I see?
There are some berries,
unidentified berries,
but lots and lots of fruit.
This is a beautiful little
jungle, rice paddy paradise here.
And I think we are on our
way now to go to a place
where they are harvesting honey.
(mysterious music)
we just took about a 15
minute drive from the house
to an area that is home to a bee farm
and this area is famous for honey.
(mysterious music)
At first we walked through the village
but now we are really getting
out here into the rice paddies
and into the mountains in a valley.
It is gorgeous walking passed the river.
Hello, hello.
Lots of friendly people.
Yeah, wow and even the air is much cooler
and not nearly as humid.
There is a mountain breeze.
I am loving it.
- The food will taste so
much better after the walk.
- Oh wow.
(speaking foreign language)
(chattering)
We got a good look at the
bees but unfortunately
is not here, whoa there's a bee.
We made it back to the village.
I think we're gonna drive
back to the house now
and I think it's time for lunch.
(chattering)
We just arrived back to the house
and we are sitting down
for a Sundanese feast,
which is food from this region.
This meal of eating
altogether is called a Botram
and they put down a couple banana leaves
and then spread rice out
into the entire middle
just filling the middle of the banana leaf
and then there are side dished all around.
This is incredible.
So all the rice is here in the middle.
So you can grab some rice
to put onto your portion of,
my portion of the banana leaf right here.
And I just took a couple
of, these are Jengkol beans,
which are similar to stink beans
and I really love Jengkol beans,
I'm gonna take a bite of that immediately.
Oh she is serving me some
of the banana blossom,
banana flower curry.
I love Jengkol.
That's like a giant stink bean.
Because it's cooked it is
kind of a sticky texture.
If you eat them raw, they are crisp.
Oh man, that is marvelous.
How is it man?
- Jengkol is one of the
best things on earth.
- [Mark] Yeah I agree.
- When people say it is
stinky, I don't get why.
- This is the banana
blossom with some shrimp.
Oh and that rice is really good as well.
That rice.
There are little fish.
I don't know if you can see,
but there are little fried fish
all mixed in with the rice.
And that gives it a really
wonderful fish fragrance.
Dude this food, oh thank you man.
I'm gonna grab some of this Sambal.
Oh yeah.
Oh pea eggplants okay.
The way the rice is
prepared with bay leaves
and with spices and is there
coconut milk in there too?
- [Man] No, no.
- No coconut milk.
Okay so it's just spices
and herbs inside the rice.
It's called (speaks in foreign language)
and oh yeah and that's with
the dried fish as well.
The crispy, little crispy dried fish
and this entire meal is ridiculously good.
I've got so many things going on.
I dug into this piece of grilled chicken.
There is a fried catfish
and so many different types
of Sambal as well.
Oh man it's just insanely good.
This is a Sambal with
chilis and there are little,
there are little pieces of
stink bean in here as well.
And it's just extraordinary flavors.
And it helps to kind of lean over
so you can get a lot of
food into your mouth.
The flavors are just insane.
I just got this little fried eel.
It looks like a little
cobra and it's curled up
and it's deep fried and
I will add some of this,
this stinky bean Sambal,
which is really good.
Alright, maybe I will break him in half.
Oh yeah it's just solidly crispy.
I'll eat that head first.
Mmmm, yeah it's just solidly deep fried.
It's crispy and then all that
flavor is in that Sambal.
Oh that's spicy, slightly
stinky bean flavor.
It's wondrous.
The food is so incredibly good.
The Jengkol beans in particular,
actually everything is good
but the Jengkol beans are
just unbelievable actually.
I just stood up to wash my
hands and I didn't realize
how full I was sitting down leaning over
but when I stand up, oh man.
I am feeling full.
And I'm soothing myself
now with another cup
of fresh coconut water.
Oh man, that was seriously
one of the most remarkable
meals both the food flavor
and also the atmosphere
and the style of eating
with the entire family.
This has just been an
incredible meal experience.
When you're eating off of
a communal leaf like that,
you never, you can't really
tell how much food you ate
until you're stuffed
because there is no plate
to like see and judge
how much food you eat
but you just keep on eating
and grabbing and eating
and grabbing and one of the
ladies just kept serving me
more and more food and I welcomed it
and that was seriously just
an incredibly remarkable meal.
(rooster crowing)
(mysterious music)
That little eel that I
just ate is right here.
(speaking foreign language)
There's a hook attached
to it and he has a little
piece of shrimp or something on the hook
and then he puts that
string down an eel hole
and just waits and hopes it bites I think.
And he already has a couple of them.
(water flowing)
Okay, guava.
That's good.
- This one is nice.
Ohh look at that.
- We are walking through
the rice fields searching
for some Pomelo.
- Pomelo.
- Yes, Pomelo.
Okay, we have come to the Pomelo tree.
This is the full Pomelo
but it's been peeled.
It has a pretty thick
skin and then pith on it.
And then this is the fruit inside.
It's actually, the actual
fruit inside is quite small,
almost like an orange size on this one.
And you typically the skin is
so thick that it's hard to eat
so you peel off all the pith
and then you just eat all
of the, the fruit inside.
Whoa, that's sour.
It's the type of sour that
makes your teeth kind of hurt
instantly but I love it.
So sour, but juicy and
crisp at the same time.
And there is something so
amazing about eating fruit
that has just been picked off
the tree just minutes ago.
It just started raining.
(rain trickling)
- [Man] So the first shot,
you cannot hit it right away.
You have to bounce it off the wall.
- Since it's raining,
we getting ready to play
a traditional Indonesian game.
It's like, it's kind of
like billiards, like pool
but it's just with your fingers.
And it's just a small square board.
- [Man] Just bounce it off this thing.
- [Mark] You flick it or you?
- [Man] Yes.
(speaking foreign language)
- It's really an addictive game.
We just sat there for and hour and played
and the time went by really fast.
We're gonna head into
Bogor now I think to eat
and then after that we're
going back to Jakarta.
(inspirational music)
We made it to Bogor and
we're gonna have dinner
at a restaurant called Ampera,
which is a Sundanese restaurant.
Oh so can he just go through the buffet
and choose whatever you want.
- And then they cook it again for you.
- And they have all the
food in buffet style
but you just go through with your plate
and choose the different
items that you want.
The dishes are all prepared
but when you order them,
then they will reheat
them, either deep fry them
or steam them or whatever
method of cooking
that they used to prepare them,
they will reheat them
that way and then you eat
everything with rice and Sambal.
So what I really wanted
to try for Sundanese food
is pepes and pepes are
little packets of either,
it can be a mixture of
different ingredients
all wrapped into a banana leaf
and I think these are steamed
and as soon as I opened
that you can smell the aroma
of herbs coming out of there.
This is chicken one?
I think it's chicken.
It looks like chicken or
it looks like chicken.
Yeah, it's chicken.
That has a really herbal flavor.
Oh man, maybe it's that bay leaf coming
in there really strongly and then also,
it has kind of a clove flavor.
I'm not sure if there are cloves in there
or cardamom or something along those lines
and then really aromatic
and then just really herbal.
They took the whole stink bean pod
and deep fried the entire thing
and then they sliced it in half
so you can have easier access
and you should just be able
to just pop these out and it
has a little skin around it.
Yeah.
Just natural vitamins.
Oh, those are pretty strong as well.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna take the next
stink bean and dip it
into the Sambal, dip it
into that chili sauce,
the rice as well.
Okay this is the original
classic with fish
and it's a little, is it a mackerel.
- [Man] Yeah I think so, mackerel.
- oh, let me take a piece of that fish
and grab some of that.
It looks like coconut down there
on you have that stink
bean on my plate still.
Wow, that fish is really really salty.
Wow, extremely salty.
I think that's just a pure salted fish.
The fish pepes was just too salty
but I think it's because
people would normally eat that
with a bunch of rice, a whole
plate of rice and just one
little bit of fish.
So, that was too salty for
me but the overall food
was really good.
We are now heading back to Jakarta.
(inspirational music)
The better oh, we're going down here.
(speaking in foreign language)
we made it back to the big city, Jakarta.
But before we go back to our hotel,
we are just stopping for a quick dessert
along the big road.
- [Man] It's Wedang Ronde.
It's a ginger soup base.
It's sweet and it has tapioca balls.
This is a regular one.
This one has peanuts in it.
- [Mark] Okay, and then what is this one?
- [Man] This one is called Sekoteng.
It is basically the same soup base
but they have like different
kind of stuff in here.
All kinds of stuff,
stuff I don't even know.
The jelly like small.
- Oh you can smell that aroma of ginger
steaming off of those bowls.
That ginger is so soothing on the throat.
And then that little dumpling
is filled with crushed peanuts
so as soon as you bite it,
it's kind of sticky and gooey,
but then as soon as you bite it,
it's like a burst of peanut
butter that comes out.
Okay next one, some of these jellies,
it looks like that's some kind of grain.
- Yep, it's called Jelly Jelly.
- This one is the same ginger soup
but then these white things
are a type of palm fruit
that is similar tasting
and feeling to coconut
but more gelatinous.
But it's kind of a similar,
yeah it's a type of palm fruit
and so that is the main ingredient
instead of the dumplings.
Yeah, I like this as a dessert
because of that strong ginger flavor.
Ying and I just made it back to the hotel.
That was a fantastic day.
The highlight being that
family feast for lunch.
That was just a once in a
lifetime meal to never forget.
I wanna say a huge thank
you to Ken and Gratiana
as well as her entire family.
Thank you very much for inviting us.
Ken and Gratiana also
have a blog and Instagram
and they also post videos on YouTube.
I'll leave all of their links
in the description box below.
Yeah that was just a great, great day.
So that is the end of this video.
Please remember to give that
thumbs up if you enjoyed it
and also make sure you
subscribe for more food videos.
Thank you again for
watching and I'll see you
on the next video.
(tropical music)